[Musique]
depuis le 1er juillet douze oeuvres ont
pris place dans le domaine nationale de
saint germain en laye un projet
d'envergure mise en place par
l'association art convergence objectif
créer du lien social à travers le monde
de l'art on a donc imaginé un parcours
artistique et sonore dans lequel des
artistes pouvaient travailler avec des
personnes en situation de handicap
psychique ou de difficultés psychiques
et d'espagne en psychiatrique et c'est
ce projet n'ont donc nés de cette
collaboration
pour cette première édition en plein air
les quatre artistes ont travaillé avec
une vingtaine de patients et des
soignants venus des centres d'accueil de
jour de rambouillet et trappes
versailles saint-germain-en-laye
ensemble ils ont imaginé un monde qui
éveille les sens
il y en a certains dans lesquels vous
pouvez entendre le dé son prix en sous
sol par des captations de micro et un
d'autres savent ça marche en alternance
lave on s'approche des troènes aider je
crois que ce sont des bruits qui sont
derrière et là vous allez avoir la voix
de mehdi qui va vous déclamer les noms
des personnes inscrites sur le monument
aux morts qui se trouve derrière pour
les patients ce travail mis en place sur
six mois aurait des bienfaits sur leur
bien-être sont le centre hospitalier de
plaisir du coup ça leur permet de
d'exister autrement que par leur maladie
de pouvoir
exprimer leurs talents artistiques et
d'être reconnus publiquement en tant que
personne entière et non pas que comme
patients souffrant de maladies
psychiques
ça leur permet de reprendre confiance en
eux et des fois de leur faire découvrir
leurs talents artistiques et leur
créativité pour voir leur créativité
l'exposition jardins de mémoire l'art du
partage et à retrouver jusqu'au 1er
octobre à saint germain en laye